welcome to this video about AWS Bedrock
if you are new to cloud or looking to
get up to the speed on AWS this is the
perfect place to start AWS Bedrock is a
foundation considering of a set of AWS
services that can be used to build
reusable and scalable applications in
this video we will cover what AWS
Bedrock consists of and why it's
important to use it whether you are a
seasoned developer or just getting
started you will learn about AWS bedrock
in just a minute so let's dive in but
before that cloud computing is a highly
technical field and having a right
certification can set you apart from the
competition consider getting certified
in popular cloud computing platforms
like AWS Azure or Google Cloud now to
help you with this step we have our
Kel-Tec postgraduate program in cloud
computing this course will help you
become an expert in Azure AWS and gcp
and let you master fundamental
architecture principles and develop the
skills needed to become a cloud expert
this postgraduate program in cloud
computing will help you become an expert
in designing planning and scaling Cloud
implementations after completing this
course you will gain Caltech ctme post
graduate certificate with 40 plus
Hands-On projects you can check out its
Link in the description box below
and I am currently living in Nigeria I
wanted to experience what is like to
live I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a personal
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech with this course I had the
choice to study while I come to Japan
that is how I got this new job offered
with 60 salary high in Finland I will be
leading the cloud computing unit of my
new company we cannot wait to start our
new life in Finland we are all Civics
now let's see the agenda for this video
in this video we will what is Amazon
Bedrock after that
what can Amazon Bedrock do moving ahead
we will see what is a foundational model
and then we will see the use cases of
AWS bedrock and conclude this video so
there is no doubt that major tech
companies are actively completing to
gain a significant share of a rapidly
expanding artificial intelligence Market
the release of open AI revolutionary
charge apt service has further
intensified this race capturing the both
interest of I.T and non-it professionals
according to various reports the IT
industry is predicted to survey to a
value of 90 billion dollar or more than
that by 2025. now let's see what is a
Amazon bedrock Amazon Bedrock is a
recently launched machine learning
platform by Amazon web services that
provides user with a convinced way to
build and expand AI application using
Foundation model also known as FMS this
platform greatly accelerates the
development process by leveraging
foundational model without the need of
handle physical infrastructure or the
associated operational complexities
also users have the flexibility to
choose from a variety of foundational
models including those offered by AI 21
Labs anthropic or internally by AWS
additionally organization can customize
these Foundation model using their own
data and utilize similar AWS tools and
capabilities ensuring the development of
scalable and highly secure generative AI
applications
now let's see what Amazon Bedrock can do
Amazon Bedrock a user-friendly machine
learning platform similar to Amazon Sage
maker enables the building and scaly
building of a generative AI application
using Foundation model unlike the sage
maker which ml Engineers commonly used
for custom model development Bedrock
focuses on leveraging FMS for ease of
use now you must be thinking what FM is
now let's see what is a foundation model
foundational model also known as FMS are
models that are trained on diverse data
and can be adapted by multiple
Downstream tasks unlike High Learning
model designed for specific use cases
foundational models serve as a
foundation that can be utilized across
various applications instead of
investing extensive time and resources
into training separate custom models for
specific tasks the focus is on the
building adaptable and versatile model
capable of Performing multiple functions
this approach promotes efficiency by
creating a model that can handle various
tasks rather than a specified model
limited to a single process now you must
have gotten the idea what foundational
model is now let's see the use cases of
Amazon bedrock
Next Generation it enables the
generation of originally written content
such as short stories social media posts
articles web page copy and even School
essays
now we have chat boards Bedrock
facilitates the creation of conventional
interfaces like chatbots and virtual
assistants to ensure user experience
integration with Amazon legs AWS chatbot
Services may be possible
next we have search in search user can
easily search find and get the
information from a diverse data sources
along various questions
moving ahead we have text summarization
this platform offers the capability to
summarize text content from sources like
blog posts essays books and documents
providing conscious summaries without
the need for lengthy rating
next we have image generation Amazon
beddraw can generate realistic and
artistic image based on specific subject
environment and scenes
next we have personalization the
platform's AI service enables
personalized customer interaction
allowing user to search for exactly what
they are looking for with the relevant
product key recommendations now Amazon
bedrock and empowers user to build and
scale generative AI application for
tasks such as text generation chat Bots
search and text summarization image
generation and personalization of
approach to leveraging foundational
models now in conclusion Amazon Bedrock
is a powerful machine learning platform
offered by AWS along user to build and
scale generative AI application using
foundational model with the rapid growth
of the AI Market Amazon Bedrock position
itself as a valuable tool for
organization looking to generative AI
without the complexities of custom model
development by leveraging foundational
model user can unlock the potential of
AI in areas such as text generation chat
boards search summarization image
generation and personalization driving
Innovation and ensuring user experience
so with this we have reached the end of
this video make sure to like and share
this video And subscribe to Simply
learns YouTube channel thank you
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here